I'm gonna lose 10 pounds and then gain 20.
I'm gonna start flossing more two days before my dentist appointment.
I'm gonna cut down on beer except for happy hour.
I love beer.
I'm going to start being more eco-friendly...
...unless I can't figure out if something's recyclable like this.
This is going in the trash.
I'm gonna keep my house cleaner but probably only when I'm having people over.
I'm gonna pick up piano unless it's really hard then I'm over it.
I'm gonna start reading more literature.
Well, probably only if it's going to be made into a movie like 50 Shades.
You know, I'm going to be a vegetarian probably until I smell bacon.
I'm gonna stop checking Facebook.
Oh, Mary got engaged.
Congrats.